hello everyone if you bring a lot of
chess players to the same place and make
them play chess some interesting
positions will definitely occur and the
$2,000,000 will definitely gather a lot
of chess players in the same place it's
been really hard choosing the games to
show as there are so many interesting
games this game here in particular
really you know caught my attention and
I really think rapid is becoming one of
my favorite time formats if not the
favorite one as all the games are quite
amazing this game here Sergey Caron has
the white pieces against a Russian feed
a master andreas panko and although
Andres a feed a master he's rating in
classical chest is somewhere around
twenty five hundred and sixty something
so I'm definitely curious was the reason
to him still being a feed a master with
such a high rating and I did take the
liberty of naming this game the Russian
beauty but you know if a game is a
beauty you don't know why the game is a
beauty but we'll get to that the game
was played in round eight and correct in
plays efore SE panko goes for c6 the
caro-kann defense Knight to f3 and d5
Knight to c3
we have Bishop to g4 h3 Bishop captures
Queen captures and Knight to f6 and here
Kerrigan certainly has a couple of
options he can push d4 he can capture he
can play Bishop to e2 but he goes for
the d3 we had e six Bishop to d2 and
Queen to b6 now attacking the B to pawn
kurakin castles Queen side and we have
d4 now Knight to e2 and it's not n c5
and it's not that white position is bad
or anything it's you have to be very
careful your pieces are really boxed in
here the idea is something like g4
followed by g5 to kick away the knight
would definitely go in favor of white
but hurricane decides to do this with E
5 this opens up the Queen's detector to
be 7 point which could be useful but on
the other hand it allows this night to
jump to d5 which as a banker immediately
uses Knight to d5 and Knight to f4 as
the panco ignores this Knight place nice
the b4 it's a definitely a good square
for the knight it attacks the DA to pawn
capturing the knight isn't really
recommended after Bishop after pawn
captures a lot of lines will be open
towards the white king so King to be one
defending the a to pawn and we have
Knight to d7 Queen to b4 defending d5
Knight as the Knight d5 pawn as the
knight was attacking it and Knight to c6
now with a double attack on the e5 pawn
and instead of well you can't really
defend this pawn kurakin plays Knight to
h5 and what's the idea here kurakin once
been good to play Knight see captures on
e5 after that he wants to push f4 after
the knight retreats he wants to push f5
and for the price of one point he he
kind of did get something started here
but after this night to h5 idea by
Carquinez Bangkok totally ignores him
and castles Queen side f4 by kurakin now
d b5 point is protected and c4 comes
upon sacrifice by C Penco so the bishop
from f8 can come to a3 and immediately
join the attack on the Queen side D
captures on c4 by kurakin we have Bishop
to a3 the threat of course is queen
capture some b2 this will be checkmate
and the bishop to c1 there is also the
option of playing b3 you could defend
like this but probably Carrigan's logic
here was the pawn can always come to b3
better not push any pawns if you don't
have to which is usually a good idea
Bishop to c1 and nice the c5 now the
other night joins the attack quickly
with a temple on the Queen Queen to f3
by kurakin and now d3 or another pawn
sacrifice to to get things started even
faster C captors on d3
and there really isn't a lot of a lot of
moves you can do here you could play
something like c3 maybe rook to d2 but
nothing nothing is really good for white
here Kirk and plays seek after sandy 3
which is probably the most resilient
move and now comes Knight to a4
with a triple attack on the B to pawn
rook to d2 kurakin brings another
defender of the B to pawn and now comes
the night to D for the other night also
comes into the attack with a temple on
the Queen Queen to f2 now the queen is
also guarding b2 and also kind of
pinning tonight it would it would
definitely be in cariocans favor if he
could exchange Queens here but Knights
the c3 check King to a-1 and here it
comes I'm sure you can all guess the
move hence the title the russian beauty
here as a banker plays Queen to b3 and
the idea of course is he wants to play
Queen captures and a2 this will be
checkmate if you capture the Queen of
course Knight character Sam B 3 is also
checkmate if you don't capture the Queen
for example if you capture the bishop
then Queen the b1 is checkmate so the
only option Cara can head here is to
play B captures knight on c3 Queen
captures and c3 this would check you
can't play King to be won or you get
Queen captures on C 1 this will be
checkmate
so Bishop to b2 Bishop captures would
check again you can go Kings to be 1 as
Queen to c1 is still checkmate rook to
be 2 was played capturing the bishop but
now comes Queen to c1 check rook to be
one blocking and now comes nice to see -
this is check the King has nowhere to go
Cara can must part with his queen so
Queen captures and c2 Queen captures and
C 2 and G 3 now probably with the idea
of playing Bishop - G - maybe sacrifice
the bishop to get the other broke into
the game but b5 is played see capture
son b5 and rook to d4 and in this
position
Sergey Kerrigan the former challenger to
the for the World Championship and the
the guy to call Minister of Defense
resigned at the game there's really
nothing to do here
white white leader has to play something
like Bishop to G to give up a piece but
today you're just down even more
material if you play any other move
Knight captures on g7 then you're you're
in checkmate Queen c3 check now rugby to
rope to be for the
was the idea of group 2d for the threat
of course is Queen characters and be to
checkmate sorry and after white defends
this simply Queen c1 check row cast the
block and queen or rook captures and b1
this is checkmate so a brilliant game
bye-bye young Russian feeder master I
think andreas been quiz 15 years old now
and if anyone has any idea how come
she's still a feeder master with a
rating of over twenty five hundred and
sixty I believe do share in the comments
so that's the game
Sergei kurakin versus se panco in round
eight I do hope you enjoyed it as usual
you can check two of my previous videos
here thank you all for watching and feel
free to suggest your own favorite game
from the world rapid championship I will
be sure to check all the comments I use
hashtag suggestion please thank you all
and I will see you soon